One of the greatest questionnaires in the
history of 20th-century psychology had a modest
start in the pages of a local Colorado newspaper
The Rocky Mountain News in July 1985. The
work of two University of Denver psychologists
Cindy Hazan and Phillip Shaver, the questionnaire
asked readers to identify which of three statements
most closely reflected who they were in love.
Image result for rocky mountains To hugely
improve our chances of thriving in relationships,
we should dare to take the same test: A: I
find it relatively easy to get close to others
and am comfortable depending on them and having
them depend on me. I don’t worry about being
abandoned or about someone getting too close
to me. B: I find that others are reluctant
to get as close as I would like. I often worry
that my partner doesn’t really love me or
won’t want to stay with me. I want to get
very close to my partner, and this sometimes
scares people away. C: I am somewhat uncomfortable
being close to others; I find it difficult
to trust them completely, difficult to allow
myself to depend on them. I am nervous when
anyone gets too close, and often, others want
me to be more intimate than I feel comfortable
being. Behind the scenes, the options refer
to the three main styles of relating to others
first identified by the English psychologist
John Bowlby, the inventor of Attachment Theory
in the 1950s and 60s. Option A signals what
is known as a secure pattern of attachment,
whereby love and trust come easily. Option
B is known as anxious attachment, where one
longs to be intimate with others but is continuously
scared of letdown and often precipitates crises
in relationships through counter-productively
aggressive behaviour. And Option C refers
to the avoidant pattern of attachment, where
it feels much easier to avoid the dangers
of intimacy through solitary activities and
emotional withdrawal. Questionnaires in newspapers
are rarely of much use but Hazan’s and Shaver’s
is the momentous exception. If there is one
thing we should do to improve our relationships,
it is to know which of the three categories
we predominantly belong to – and to deploy
the knowledge in love so as to warn ourselves
and others of the traps we might fall into.
We then need a little training because half
of us at least are not secure in love; we
belong in the camps of either the avoidant
or the anxious, and we have – to complicate
matters – an above average propensity to
fall in love with someone from the other damaged
side, thereby aggravating our insecurities
and defences in the process. Niccolo Pisano
An Idyll: Daphnis and Chloe Here is a brief
list of what avoidants and anxious types should
keep in mind in their relationships: IF YOU
ARE AN AVOIDANT WITH SOMEONE ANXIOUSLY ATTACHED
Recognise the extent to which you check out
emotionally when things are intense, particularly
when there is an offer of closeness. Recognise
how you will tend to prefer sex and closeness
with strangers and how nervous you will be
around cuddles and kissing. You probably don’t
want the light on either. Watch how you sabotage
long-term intimacy. Have compassion that you
are afraid of what you really want. Think
back to how in your past, closeness would
have been frightening because people let you
down, and observe how you adopted a strategy
of removal to protect yourself. You are hurt,
not bad. Remind yourself that the present
is different from the past and that you are
ruining the present by bringing to it fear-laden
dynamics that don’t belong there. It may
feel like your partner is being aggressive
and ill-tempered with you for no reason; they
are at heart upset and unable to express their
needs in any other way. They want you; and
that is why they are behaving as they are.
Look beneath their nagging and their accusations
and believe in their underlying goodwill.
When they attack you, see their longing for
love. Do that very frightening thing: extend
reassurance. And explain, calmly, the appeal
of the cave. IF YOU ARE AN ANXIOUS PERSON
WITH AN AVOIDANT PARTNER Things are not necessarily
as bad as they seem. Their quiet might just
be quiet, not a lack of love. Their distance
isn’t meanness, it’s their way of maintaining
equilibrium. You are not demented or ‘needy’
to want more; but your way of dealing with
what you legitimately need is aggravating
things hugely. You are triggering your partner
by asking for intimacy too directly and also
(probably) with too much anger. Realise that
you need to tread lightly, and to be a little
distant in requesting closeness. The partner
isn’t mean or freakish; merely damaged – as
are you. And that’s very normal. A full
40% of the population are in your positions.
Knowing whether we can be classed as secure,
avoidant or anxious in love should be a basic
fact we grasp about ourselves. The next step
is to accept with grace that if we are either
avoidant or anxious, we will need considerable
emotional schooling to get out of scratchy
patterns and stand a chance of building up
a good enough relationship.
Our Relationships Book calmly guides us with calm and charm through the key issues of relationships.
To ensure that success in love need not be a matter of luck.  For more click the link now.